thanks for a little Easter appreciated
that we on okay uh this is vo Robbie why
did you get into the snack food business
uh well basically my friends Ryan and
Todd we have a company called this bar
saves lives for every bar we sell we
donate a life-saving meal packet to
child in need somewhere around the world
and Ryan and Todd took a trip to Africa
they're introduced to this meal packet
called Plumpy'nut which is prescribed to
kids who are days away from dying from
severe acute malnutrition which affects
20 million kids under the age of six
every year so we want to figure out a
way to to give and keep on giving so
that's great why not find something that
you know allows
we'll Hillary seed to any of Bernie's
demands should she
tap nope they hate each other they have
only Haiti thank you you know they don't
Haiti
nothing hard it hasn't she knows she has
to she knows she has already done it
yeah yeah but she's gonna keep doing it
he's obviously not going anywhere he's
doing they're not their pressures on and
they're not that much at odds anyway I
mean they're not they're not they have
so much so much more well Freddie when
you're in the Senate they voted together
like 93% of the differences are by
degrees and she's gonna she knows she
has she can't be the bad guy she can't
afford to be the bad guy here
people are so tweezed that he's the wild
card he doesn't he believes that he's
got this revolution going he's knock I
mean look at he's just made this very
long videotape yesterday saying he's
still running
I mean area he's also enjoy
I mean everybody else would be out by
this point I mean but he is just I'm
Stephen Lewis
I think the wild card is the Republican
voter who is trying to decide if they
will at all cost vote for anyone that
runs for their party like I think
they're looking at a trumpet for the
first time saying this guy's [ __ ] nuts
I can't support I just can't and that's
the people are saying I know what you're
hearing right now is hearing a lot of
politicians say the worst things about
him then say yeah but I'm gonna favor in
Hollywood it is it's really not I mean
it's really but I traveled this country
I land in the flyover State do you like
stay at the Holiday Inn no why would
that help me understand with normal
people
ladies the holiday is I think that I if
I passed me I guess
I've entered a Republican candidate
you're gonna have some republicans
voting for Hillary hi Wow I'm sure I
mean you know and you're not a lot of
them does not vote at all look I see you
guys are way ahead on this too far ahead
I've interviewed Trump many times
recently as last week
I've sat down at them there's a part of
Trump that the public has not seen yet
because he's got these bit Crowley oh
wow and one yes I can't wait I mean that
guy's really first from this table his
okay but that's a long rebel a wait wait
she's been in public life for like 35
I'm just saying but there's something we
haven't seen matters that is deep deep
deep down in both my experience of
interviewing him many times sitting with
him he is thoughtful he is intelligent
yeah
focused he has calm and you're gonna
sigh then why doesn't it been a year why
just me exhibit any of that in public
it's he's in yeah he doesn't sit-down
interviews you also wrote a book on
Emily that's a gun I mean I just don't
think your point of view on Trump is
that valid
that's not bean that was easy though yes
I just wanted to make the friends I just
do it necessary it's hard enough to come
here when the crowd is against ya know
it's hard I shouldn't have done that I'm
so that's alright uh um
why is Donald Trump such an enormous
douche bag no I'm sorry that that's
terrible
what do you make of recent reports that
Donald Trump wants to establish a new
media company he has cut off a lot of I
think he I think that's a heard from
sources inside it's a very likely thing
but you can't think that's a great idea
to like cut off well there's a good one
there's Fox News and then there's where
I work one American news there's very
few right-leaning
24-hour seven news sources then you've
got CNBC MSNBC ABC NBC CBS you got all
the left forum out there is it left lean
are you kidding me I am not kidding you
where are they their money leaning oh
everybody's money everybody lovely yeah
that'd be they would have to learn
something new get left-leaning
date I just I worked at ABC News and NBC
News I was always the only open
conservative they're everybody's openly
liberal so if I'm talking from personal
experience but they are left-leaning but
obviously they root for the horse race
everybody wants to make money that's I
drew on that Booker isn't Donald Trump
me maybe like anyone pneumatically gonna
be president like isn't it a conflict of
interest what were the president to run
a media organization on jump ahead
that's very good
okay but but even so don't you think
it's a mistake to cut off somebody like
the Washington Post and and many others
I mean it's kind of third world that's a
honey Rock a Banana Republic Barack
Obama did the same thing in 2008 cut off
their credential moth the plane even
worse than Washington's a near coast and
the doubt yes it is people which can
track any access whatsoever okay he'd
never did he kicked up once this is
doors McCain he kicked off the plane
three newspapers to endorse McCain on
the editorial page the washing Times the
New York Post and the Dallas Morning
News
in 2008 nobody sees our problem with
that it is polished I mean once you're
in the White House White House the White
House Correspondents Association takes
over you can't do these things but as
long as you're running a campaign you
control the planes you control the
private events it's politics it's just
what it is I'm not sure about all that
but I value freedom of the press
obviously that's what I do for living
however politicians are politicians and
they do what they want to win that's
both sides okay all right good night